okay so I guess let's start so we're
super excited to have Nick talking to us
about this very recent new work about
the discrete Gaussian as I understand it
about sort of the distribution of calm
belief convolutions of discrete
gaussians which sign that comes up sort
of all over the place and in lattice
crypto and also in lattice algorithms so
Nick is currently a postdoc at Rutgers
with Steven Miller before that he got
his PhD with Daniel a and he's just
generally kind of cool so so we're
excited to have him and right so if you
have questions please type in chat
either the question itself or just the
fact that you have a question try not to
interrupt the speaker sort of
mid-sentence because with the lag and
that tends not to work so well and with
that I'll let Nick start thank you yeah
so I'll be talking about our work
improve discrete Gaussian and sub
Gaussian Alice for a lot it's
cryptography this is doing work joint
work with Danielle at Michoud show Chris
[ __ ] and Michael Walter and this is to
appear in pkc 2020 okay there we go so
the the goal of our work it's to provide
a simple framework for analyzing
discrete Gaussian so like a simpler and
modular modular approach for analyzing
them and if you look in the literature
you'll often see that many of the
discrete Gaussian like convolution
theorems or the discrete Gaussian
analysis theorems they they're all kind
of proof from scratch each time but at
least it's spirit they're all extremely
similar like they all boil down to like
one or two smoothness conditions so our
hope is or was maybe we can have a
simple theorem or a simple smoothness
condition such that it would imply all
of these other analyses and hopefully
this would give like a modular framework
for future analyses of operations on the
scree cow scenes and what we found is
yes there is a simple characterization
and it's usually after maybe one or two
steps you can always show that the
analysis boils down to the discrete
Gaussian being smooth in the kernel of
some linear transformation okay so an
overview of the talk first I'm going to
give some background that I'm going to
talk about linear transformations of
discrete Gaussian and then next I'm
going to talk about a tighter analysis
of generating LWT samples with discrete
Gaussian error and then after that
general convolutions of the scree
calcium's
and as a secondary contribution over
paper we have in our paper we have some
tighter analysis on sub Gaussian
matrices okay so this is the lattice
seminar we all know what a lattice is
but just to review a whole lattices of
the scripts discrete subgroup of
euclidean space equivalently you could
take all integer combinations of some
basis and importantly for us is the dual
lattice so this is the it's also lettuce
and it's the all the vectors in the span
of the lattice the linear span that is
that when they when you take the inner
product with the lattice in these
vectors you get you've lined back in the
integers okay so most of the talk when
we talk about discrete gaussians just to
review the the street Gaussian over a
lattice lambda it is the probability
distribution such that the probability
of sampling a vector X in the lattice is
proportional to the Gaussian function
and important for us is the the Gaussian
with this tells you how wide the
distribution is and you can also have a
non-0 center the center doesn't need
necessarily be in the lattice later on
through the throughout the talk often
we're just going to work with s here
equals one and so if you see this row
without a subscript one that just means
s is equal to one and also we're gonna
throw away the center because you can
always take the discrete cows you know
real the lightest Cosette
so to shift all the points by by the
center and then have the zero centered
let's greet Gaussian but it's on a
lattice Cosette now instead of a lattice
still everything's perfectly defined
okay sorry Nikolas is called big can you
hear me yes I can you so so you can do
this shoe but that means that you have
to make sure that all your theorem
statements don't just apply to draw
Santa letters but to shift the lattices
is that correct right and they do so
should I just be whenever so hands fall
but you just think about should the
lattices yeah so this this equation is
is what so if you do want to ship the
lattice to a non-zero center that you
can always have this equation in in your
mind right so you can always take it
over a lattice cosine and then shift
just add this this vector C I guess I'll
Nick saying is that like there are two
different ways that people tend to
describe like a shift to discrete
Gaussian like one is like as a discrete
Gaussian over a lattice that's where the
distribution itself is shifted and the
other is like a distribution over a
lattice coset and he's just pointing out
that these are the same thing so I guess
and you're saying that you're gonna use
like the the latter notation like the
distribution over a cosine as opposed to
the distribution over the lattice with a
shifted correct yeah well and this is
what we do in applications see if we we
usually shift are usually simple I'm
a-gonna Cosette and then shift by a
sensor anyway
so in applications often will have a
non-spherical discrete Gaussian this is
where say you take a positive definite
matrix Sigma and then now the
probability that a X here is sampled is
not proportional to the the real
function with this inverse covariance
matrix here and we write square root
Sigma because there's there's many
different square roots that you can take
for for each Sigma and sometimes picking
them wisely might help you with analysis
with your like analysis and the proof
may be but in the end it's still the
same distribution okay so as we all know
the screen gaussians are kind of
duplicate of ubiquitous with lattices
and mathematics cryptography and flexp
so we have a question so the question is
how to think about a non spherical
Gaussian geometrically one let's see one
simple way is if you have a invertible
matrix you could just map the discrete
Gaussian so that would that would shift
everything morphed and distribution but
really it's it's it's going to be
instead of concentrated around the
sphere in in Euclidean space is going to
be concentrated around like an ellipsoid
so like when you when you think of the
secrete Gaussian Zoar gaussians really
you usually think of like a blurry
sphere and and a non spherical discrete
Gaussian maybe a blurry ellipsoid okay
so so in mathematics discrete Gaussian
so they give some of our tightest
transference theorems
these these are theorems relating the
shortness of vectors and primary lettis
compared to the shortness of vectors in
the dual lattice they give us unless
cryptography complexly they give us our
tightest worst case average gets
reductions in algorithms they had they
give us the fastest algorithms to solve
SVP and CVP exactly four lattice
signatures they are they they give us
our digital signature schemes that have
the smaller signature size for advanced
trapdoors they're at the heart of many
of our applications like ib e AV e GG h
15 multilinear maps and it's
applications and and also something such
as like function hiding fhe okay so
let's see it's my bar blocking there we
go okay it's not too hard to plot a one
dimensional discrete Gaussian orbit
integers and what you'll notice is if
you take the scree Gaussian and then
[Music]
shift it sorry taking the scree cows you
know integers and then shift it by the
point farthest away from the integers
are 0.5 you'll see a noticeable
difference in the Gaussian mass of these
two distributions or these two functions
now what you can do is you can actually
make the Gaussian much wider and then
when you still has to meet the Gaussian
mess it doesn't matter where on the real
line you pick the Gaussian mass is going
to be almost the same or it's not
noticeably different and when when
thinking about the the Gaussian function
there's two equivalent ways to think
about this this is either that the same
mass here could be gotten by taking the
integers and scaling it by 1 over 10 and
then just having s here equals to 1 so
really this is kind of like this is a
statement about the density of Z in a
sense okay so now these these previous
pictures they motivate smoothness for
discrete gaussians and intuitively all
we think about when we think about for
the screed Gaussian is smooth is whether
or not it behaves like a continuous
Gaussian Niek sorry so thick again and
you go back to the previous picture the
previous slide again yeah what would you
like us to pay attention doing the two
pictures they look identical to me it's
at the point ah yeah okay so this is
actually off-center so thank you
well yeah when you're taking Gaussian
mass it doesn't matter if this is 0.5 or
a thousand point five it just matters
how far you are away from the lightest
so that's why I picked this such a small
center I see
mmm and point five is the farthest away
you can get from minsters and sorry I'm
still not quite sure what should I be
pay attention doing the two pictures
that that the two gaussians they're not
the same right right but their mass is
almost the same so like their masses no
not noticeably different whereas before
in this in this much more narrow
Gaussian or much like less dense version
the the two Gaussian masses are no it's
really different
okay um so I think oh when you say mass
are the same and not the same they're
sort of the same way we talked about the
distribution statistically close yes so
that in the end that's that's that's
that's a very related yes okay thanks
okay so we're gonna talk about that okay
okay so yes so yeah
so in in the we're looking forward we
are going to use smoothness to argue
that distributions are statistically
close yeah now before we get there
though I have to define the smoothing
parameter and so if you fix some small
epsilon greater than the greater than
zero the smoothing parameter it's this
kind of funny quantity that's a that is
asked how far do you have to push away
the points in the dual lattice such that
the Gaussian mass is at most 1 plus
Epsilon
and you'll notice here that you can't
get rid of this one because you always
have zero in the lattice but really this
is a statement about the density of the
lattice because if you scale the dual by
us you're scaling the lattice by 1 over
X or 1 over s okay and then just loosely
speaking we'll say like a discrete
Gaussian is smooth if it's if its width
is greater than the smoothing parameter
for some negligible Epsilon okay so
smooth discontinued we can extend this
to non spherical discreet gaussians via
the same manner you could take some
square root of a positive definite
matrix and in the US if it's it is
greater than the swoony parameter if
when you push away the dual lattice
points by this by this matrix this
invertible matrix
if the Gaussian mass is less than 1 plus
epsilon or equivalently if you can take
the scale of the lattice by the inverse
now importantly for us is are the
consequences of smoothness so the
Gaussian mass when you're working with a
smooth smooth lettuce it's gonna be
approximately 1 over the determinate and
if you really have an S here that's
different than 1 this would be s to the
N over the determinant and if this were
a Sigma you would have like but
Sigma and really importantly for us is
that the Gaussian is shift invariance so
this is something that we're going to
use repeatedly today over and over again
that that the Gaussian masses Shipton
burn or the Gaussian itself distribution
is shift invariant and this this of
course happens for discrete or
continuous gaussians because shifting
the center is just to change variables
and the integrals are equal okay
and also importantly for us or for
applications we have efficient
algorithms so that's more or less what
give us all of our applications so we
can sample these distributions
efficiently and also so we're spoon this
first came about were tight worst case
the average case reductions for sis so
if you have a smooth lattice than
generating an sis instance is there's a
given by taking a Gaussian over RN and
then taking the Gaussian mass modulo of
the lattice okay so now I'm gonna talk
about the new transformations of
discrete Gaussian the the simplest case
we can think of is what happens when we
have a injective linear transformation
then you can see pretty quickly that
these two distributions or these two
statistical experiments are equal you
can first sample the discrete Gaussian
and then you can map by the linear
transformation or you can just sample
from the the range immediately given by
what you would get by the transforms
distribution the transforms the Matt's
domain and the Matt's covariance or a
shape okay
now a little bit a little bit more
advanced is what yeah it's to human
Chancellor oh yeah so for this to make
sense T yeah so the this the lattice
cosa must be in the same spaces there in
the the span of T yeah or it must be in
the range that T is defined on the span
of the lettuce okay all right you're
welcome yeah all right so a little bit
more advances say we have a smooth
lettuce say just that it's not full rank
and what would be in the Gaussian mess
if we were to take and a fine or if we
were to taken to find some of the
slightest so we're to kind of push it
away from its span well the Gaussian
mass we would think would be would decay
proportionally with how far away we are
from the the lattices original span and
you can see that mathematically by
writing out the center we're writing out
this the C as an authorial decomposition
where C is lambda is in the span of
lambda and C perpend is orthogonal to
for the span and the reason is that once
once you have orthogonality this
constant term pops out of the Gaussian
function but that is okay Nick let me
just see if I understand so you're
saying that like this this fact that you
told us before that if you shift the
lattice by some factor and you're above
smoothing the mass doesn't change this
is true if the vectors in the span of
the lattice it sort of necessarily not
true if the vector is not in the span of
the lattice because sort of if you go
orthogonal to the last and just sort of
all vectors get farther away from the
origin so like mass just has to go down
so now you're like handling the more
general case when you're shifting
outside of the span of the lattice and
you get this term that like depends on
the orthogonal part of seat of the ship
yes yes exactly yeah and really we can
see it by this picture right so if we
pre take the lettuce and this is the
span of the lettuce and we shift it
first you can see that
okay the Gaussian is a radial function
so it should decrease with how far away
we are and we need spoon this because we
we want this to be independent of
whatever co set were in up here okay so
this this picture is going to help us
help us later on - all right so a
slightly more complex case is what about
orthogonal projections so real quick say
we have a general lattice cosa say we
have P as a subspace which we call a
lattice subspace and what that means is
that the intersection of the lattice and
P is full rank in P or that this this
intersection lettuce is a full rank
lattice in this span or in P and if we
have the lattice in this direction is
smooth when we project out this this we
project out this direction then the
following two experiments are
statistically close which we're going to
see why in a second but this is taking a
discrete Gaussian over the co set a and
then projecting or orthogonal a it's a P
or you can just project the coset
orthogonal e2p right away and take a
discrete Gaussian over the projection
okay so why is that if we look at the
the
right hand side here so we want to look
at we want to fix a V in in the
projection of a and then really the
Gaussian mass is going to be
proportional to everything we project
out and you kind of have to tilt your
head here because the picture it's it's
rotated compared to the last picture but
we're gonna see that what we really need
here is this this shift invariance so it
doesn't matter which co set we pick as
long as the Gaussian is early as long as
we are smooth in that direction okay
okay so what about a general linear
transformation and the general discrete
Gaussian so just to set the table T is
here again a general image
transformation a is a lattice kosa we
have some small number epsilon s is full
column rank and we have the A's and is
inside the span of s and we also have
that the kernel is a lattice sub space
so the lattice is full rank in the
kernel now with with these the most
important thing to consider is that the
lettuce is smooth in the kernel so it's
full ring this is just so what you get
is a lettuce but really what we need is
this this condition this spoon this
condition and if you have the smoothest
condition then these two statistical
experiments that you could run are
statistically close so you can take the
take a sample from the lattice and
transform it or you can sample directly
from the transformed domain and shape so
more just more concisely we just need a
smooth kernel for for this list of hold
and right away might not like seen that
obvious but what we're going to see is
that this this Colonel condition is
going to appear over and over again in
in applications and the theorems we talk
about this topic again so the chronic
conditions the the the the equation that
stands out on the left hand side is a
smoothing parameter I taught on 11 sites
in number and you have less than or
equal to s which is a matrix the time is
understand something okay so the
smoothing parameter is defined for a
lattice correct and this this is a
lattice this is the the lattice
restricted through the kernel of this
transformation and eight epsilon is
number no yes yeah so what does it mean
for a number to be less than or equal to
a matrix well that's one way to think
about it is the singular values so if
this is equivalent to the singular
values being greater than than this
number right but this is the notation
that we use repeatedly that so we say so
in if this was just a number this would
be how far away in the dual do we have
to push out the lattice for and such
that the Gaussian mass is small the same
thing happens here except now you have
an S inverse Nick are you really
thinking about ADA epsilon as ADA
epsilon times the identity matrix and
the less than or equal to means that the
difference between two matrices is
positive definite that that's equivalent
to yeah so you can you can if you want
to work with squares so you could take
the square and the identity and then you
can work with s times s transpose IV
Sigma and then yeah then it'd be a
statement about them I give values say I
don't I don't think it's equivalent it's
it's it's like sufficient but it's not
necessary right so this is just it's an
abuse of notation it means that if you
scale the jewel up by s then the dual
has mass less than 1 plus epsilon or
like equivalently if
like you apply as inverse to to your
original lattice then it should be
smooth no all right so just it's just
abused notation right I see okay and
before we continue it's important to
note that a special case of this theorem
was proved before a paper was online
this is in the paper that's going to
appear in Europe 2020 by Duke a
lugubrious press and you so some similar
analysis later and the line could
possibly be done with with their
theorems here all right so as and the
first application let's look at
generating LWT samples so quickly to
review the Eldar redistribution is
you're given a truly uniformly random
vector a with each other entries mod Q
and you're given a inner product with a
secret vector s and you're going to
scramble the low order bits and here
we're only going to concern ourselves
with e taken the screen as a discrete
Gaussian and most often in applications
we were going to express these in matrix
form so a here is going to be some so if
we have say M samples with M which is
larger than n we we can express this as
a short and fat matrix a and then the
inner products there you could just view
them as treating a as a generator matrix
for code say and then the errors are
just these this independently sample
load norm vector and the elderly
distinguishing problem is when when can
you distinguish this distribution from
getting something that's truly uniformly
random okay
so from the very beginning we've had
these elderberry self reductions where
you have elderberry samples and you want
to generate new samples with the same
secret and you want them to be close to
statistically independent from each
other or the the the air is to be
independent from each other but it's
important note that the the previous
self or self reductions
they were the proofs we if you were to
go to analyze you'd have to artificially
add continuous Gaussian noise and this
would make the proof and direct but it
would also add some a slight artificial
bump in the noise now it's important to
say it's a note here that the reductions
themselves were discrete but the proofs
were continued or added some continuous
noise so a question is can we do this
directly without this artificially added
continuous Gaussian noise okay and then
whenever we do so here in this picture
this dollar sign just means like some
some independent randomness we take some
other elderberries samples and we want
some yeah some other examples
independent noise and mapping the
uniform case the uniform that's that's
pretty easy that should happen
regardless guess salinization why I need
a long queue samples to recover
uniquely recover us let's see so the
reason I have n log Q is we're gonna
need this this actually the stuff that I
said was easy it's mapping uniform to
uniform is easy when you have that many
samples yeah and that's often a how many
samples we have in applications because
we'll switch between using a as a matrix
for L debris and a is using sa matrix
for
and once you have this many samples you
know sis solutions exist okay what what
here's uniform the the errors uniform or
oh the hold no use uniform right right
yeah so so what I'm saying is whatever
we do it should just map uniform to
uniform right like and that's that's
kind of like the easy stuff that's
always been the easy second I see yeah
so we're really focused about generating
all degrees samples but we don't want to
mess up that part and when you say new
independent lwe samples
you mean like the matrix a should be
independent or the matrix and also the
error yes
yeah the error and the military say yeah
but we can't change the secret right
secret is regular yeah okay okay many of
you have seen this before but which it's
the the reduction is more or less the
same as previous reductions you say we
have these other view samples okay so
now I'm just gonna reframe in terms of
taking all the resamples and generating
more elbow grease samples alright so we
have this like these L degree samples of
memory and then we want to yeah we want
to generate more all debris samples so
what we do we first take a M dimensional
discrete Gaussian map to a new vector a
and then use that same vector inner
product with what we have here and then
add a little bit of smoothing noise okay
and now the mapping uniforms uniform
part this happens as long as we were
over the smoothing parameter of this
lattice right so this this q area
lattice or this s is lettuce and we have
type bounce on this from previous I
think the tightest bound is in maybe MP
12 okay so that that the sanity check
that's good
now what about
the error here so first conditioning on
this a times X 1 gives us as a the
distribution of the error turn is this e
transpose X 1 plus this X 2 alright now
if we treat this if we were to separate
this from say we separates the scree
calcium's you could treat this as a
linear transformation a simple linear
transformation taking just the inner
product with e transpose with 1 appended
and this this discrete Gaussian over a
cosa of this Esaias lettuce with this
the last entry just being in the
integers and what is our shape here it
could be non spherical if these are ones
and if these if r1 is ie quotes r2 so
we're just yeah right a does diagonal
but you see right away that we can
express the Joint Distribution without
any effort so now all we have to do is
analyze the kernel all right okay and
using the linear transformation theorem
the kernel pops out with a little bit of
thought not too bad
so first the kernel of this of this
length transformation that's just all
real vectors here that would be V and
inner product or I'm missing a minus
sign here should be a minus sign and if
you take it with the intersection of the
lattice you get the same thing except
this V is now in the this V is now in
this this perp lettuce and with a few
more lines of effort which you go
through the paper we show with no
artificial increase in noise that this
is now a discrete Gaussian
where you can some some of these
together of course the the noise does
grow with with this area term for that
that's that's always been in there okay
I think I guess you do need something
slightly stronger right you want to say
that it's also independent of the
original II so you have to like add like
I don't know some identity or something
under its it so I yeah I did a lot with
the service here I should have written
out what the transformed lattice would
be but with a little bit of thought what
would it be it would be the the
transform discrete Gaussian right so it
would be a screed Gaussian over Z and
the noise here would be some combination
of the e the r and the are eyes I see so
so you you recover the e okay yeah so II
he comes out in terms of the width of
the noise but but you don't you don't
so let's see yes so this is this is if
if you know the the this is if you know
that what's the size of e right and in
in the actual reduction you have to do a
little bit of guessing in terms of yeah
oh I see that makes yeah yeah but in
terms of generating l degrees samples
this we just we have this this all gone
in this r2 and then it just has to be
larger than some condition on yeah some
function of the north maybe I see I see
it okay that makes sense
mmm-hmm okay and in applications often
we know the bounds on e okay okay so now
let's see what this gets us for general
convolutions okay so the the simplest
discrete Gaussian convolution of the
street gaussian some of
pulse would be let's just take to full
rank discrete gaussians and add them
together right and make them spherical
just yeah to start and this this is this
is done in Bonet and Franklin the 2011
and their paper on linear money early
homomorphic signature schemes from
lattices so say we take this x1 from
over a discrete Gaussian over a co set a
one of with s1 same thing for x2 but
different Co set different with when
would this x1 and x2 if we add them
together women to be statistically close
here or a discrete Gaussian so if you
recall the the the last slide what we
did the first thing we did is we we
wrote out the Joint Distribution and
here the Sigma is just the the identity
matrix is blocked together okay and we
express this as of linear transformation
the only transformation is very simple
just this identity matrix concatenated
itself and if we just blindly were to
shut this into V like a transformation
theorem we would need that this is this
is we would need this discrete Gaussian
to be smooth over the kernel intersect
the original lettuce and that is just
all set of vectors V and minus V such
that there in the intersection
okay let's let's do do a sanity check so
why why would this intersection come up
naturally well if you fix a Z in the the
range which is a 1 plus a 2 then the the
Gaussian mass that's mapped onto it is
gonna be all in this set so it's gonna
be all set so say you pick some some
representative from a 1 and a 2 it's
gonna be all vectors of this form where
you have the a1 and the h2 and you have
this K and the intersection such a such
that it cancels so you see that right
away this this kernel appears naturally
from the first step of the analysis ok
and this is yeah criminal okay
so oftentimes we we can't just glue them
together and get the joint distribution
without a little bit of thought so this
this next theorem is going to be when
when can we what can we do that alright
so when can we take an experiments where
savory sample X 1 from this Gaussian
over some let's go so at a 1 and then if
we shift the the co set of the second
discrete Gaussian maybe by a lot
transformation when can we just express
this as a as a single discrete Gaussian
and if you remember the the main tool
from the earlier slides is that discrete
gaussians their their shift invariant so
if we're shifting in the second lightest
coset what we need is that this lattice
needs to be smooth so if we have that
the slightest is smooth then you can
express this as a single discrete
Gaussian
can everyone think of - product in the
previous lattice product oh okay yeah
yeah okay that's that's a good point so
so this this cross product is just all
of all the set of vectors you can made
together where the first end coordinates
is just a vector in a 1 and the second
and coordinates are a vector in a 2 and
this so if we just look at the lettuces
this contains this this this sub lattice
yeah weird my bubble girl here we go
okay cool okay so back to the slide
really the what should be setting off
alarm bells here is is if we're shifting
this second cosa we need this this shift
invariance that spoon this gives us so
that's why we need the second lettuce to
be smooth okay oh no all right so if we
if we were to just write out this these
probabilities on the right hand side you
would condition or just naturally on the
left hand side say you would first
condition on X 1 and then so and this is
your your condition on X 1 and then how
would you express that conditioning
events for this this distribution which
is a single single Gaussian sample it
would be that the this simple linear
transformation the identity and it was
zero when you map it you get this X 1
back okay
so when you do that you yes so this is
this is how we can see this that in the
first step of analyzing this the the
criminal pops out naturally okay so now
we're gonna see a modular approach to
proving the Chris's convolution theorem
from 2012 they're from 2010 and say say
we do the same thing but now we have now
we have a spherical Gaussian or two
spherical gaussians and this this
happens a lot in applications because
we're we're doing some operations saying
signatures and if you would just return
the signature without this this without
any convolution you would be leaking
information about the secret keys so
instead what you do is you would take
some perturbation that where you would
pick this Sigma one wisely such that
when you add these together you can
cancel out these these are like cross
variances for these dependence
dependencies so the statistical
experiments is you're taking x1 this is
like the perturbation that doesn't
depend on the key and then you're taking
it and randomly shifting this second
discrete Gaussian by the first and then
you want to return this X here which
would be say a signature okay now if we
could blindly treat these like
continuous gaussians right away we would
have that you would get the B in the
correct range because we did a little
shift and then also that the covariances
were just some so you could cancel out
any any dependencies on secret key
material okay but it's not that simple
but really it's it's not too bad once we
start thinking about what we've done
before
so the first
the first thing we need to we need to do
is express this as a single discrete
Gaussian and from before as soon as we
start shifting this the second lattice
or this cosa that should be there should
be alarm bells going off in your head
saying oh we need Scruton this year we
need this to be shift invariant so if we
have this shift invariance then we can
treat this as a single discrete Gaussian
with the appropriate shape or
covariances so there's gonna be some
dependence on X 1 here here are some
cross variants and then some here and
then what we do is we just take the
simplest linear transformation which is
this 0 + 1 times this this distribution
though which would be the second vector
and then we have to make sure that we're
smooth enough in the kernel so here the
kernel it's actually lambda 1 plus the
zero vector but lambda 1 and if we're
smooth enough there then we are then the
output is actually this distribution so
this is now inside for the screen
Gaussian so it would be statistically
close to do this which is the
distribution that we want and when you
when you first look at this theorem you
see this kind of strange Sigma 3 shape
or this Sigma 3 matrix but this this
arise arises naturally because you can
simply like block diagonalize this Sigma
and then Sigma 3 then then pops out okay
so the the general recipe for this this
modular approach its first express your
its statistical experiment as a single
discrete Gaussian then express the
output of the experiment as a linear
transformation of that discrete Gaussian
and lastly show smoothness in the kernel
let us
okay so where where does this idea show
up it shows up kind of everywhere in
these in wherever these this analysis
arises so in regards of L debris paper
Christa 2010 paper Bono Franklin 4011 MP
12 which is on trapdoors or strong
lettuce trapdoors happy 13 which is
about elderly and Osias with small
parameters function hiding fhe the scree
calcium sampling and our our signature
paper last year okay so any any
questions before we move on to the last
part of the talk okay great so a
secondary contribution of our paper is
just some tighter analysis on sub
Gaussian matrices or sub grousing random
matrices so a random variable X is some
Gaussian with parameter s if its tail's
are dominated by a Gaussian off with us
as you would expect the discrete
Gaussian is sub Gaussian and say a
bounded random variables are discrete
Gaussian okay a random vector in RN is
sub Gaussian if it's so Gaussian in
every direction or if you take the if
the inner product this random variable
over R is sub Gaussian for any unit
vector u okay now in applications were
really worried about the singular values
of sub Gaussian random matrices so that
is just a random matrix where it's rows
are taken as independents of Gaussian
vectors and the singular values are the
square roots of the eigenvalues of this
grand majors okay so we're going to just
to note s1 of are here as the
just singular value yeah and now this is
a random variable okay so why why are we
motivated to look at this so if you
remember the SIS problem so say we have
this this a here which is the same
matrix as before it's short and fat and
uniformly random modulo Q and the SIS
problem is if you're given this this
random matrix and you're given this
random vector mod Q you want you have to
find a short vector X that maps to this
it's when you take the matrix vector
multiplication yeah and now really this
is a problem over the lattice coset so
I'm missing a parenthesis a here but
this is a cosine of the Q every lattice
defined by a okay so our motivation is
say in a trapdoor scheme what we have is
you have say a public verification key
as this random matrix a and then your
secret signing key is this random matrix
R with small entries such that when you
map this when you take the product you
get this gadget where this this G is any
matrix where s is is easy okay now in
applications what this allows you to do
it allows you to sample a discrete
Gaussian oh I'm missing an a here again
over the queue area lettuce of with that
depends directly on the the largest
singular value of this trapdoor matrix
so really this the underlying the
hardness of our Esaias problem scales
directly with the largest singular value
so we want to have a tight understanding
of this of this parameter okay oh sorry
so here you're saying that so okay
things are kind of layered on top of
each other right
like 4 MP 12 like actually the statement
that you just said the fact that this
tramped our sampling algorithm does this
is itself a consequence of your
convolution theorem right like yes so we
don't prove a new convolution theorem we
kind of just show that the modular way
gives a simple proof but yes yeah so
exactly yeah but now we're looking at
different different random variables in
a sense yeah ok cool ok cool now so the
previously known singular value bones
for say random matrix with independents
some Gaussian entries of parameter s
there's this unknown constant that
floats around and they're very tight or
so another bow that's commonly used is
if you have independents of Gaussian
rows then you get this quadratic
dependence on the sub gas in parameter s
on the smaller dimension but right away
you'll notice something is wrong because
if you scale the matrix this should
scale also so this is only for isotropic
rows
these are rows that yeah the expectation
of the cross variance is just the
identity so really you would expect
everything here to scale linearly so the
first thing we do in a paper in this
last section is we actually go through
the proofs and we find what what this
constant is it's about 38 oh we also
show that it does scale with the
standard deviation as you would expect
but this constant 38 it's kind of it's
almost too large for to be of
consequence and applications so then we
looked experimentally what is this for
commonly used distributions and and
independent entries and then there we
find something
much more interesting in my opinion is
that the the singular values they're
tightly concentrated around this this
this quantity which is Sigma times the
square root of the dimension and plus
the dimension N and we have something
similar for the lower bound on the least
smallest singular value also and this is
this is interesting because this is
exactly what you get for a Gaussian rate
matrix so for Gaussian matrices this is
known as Gordon's law
so for commonly used distributions these
singular values they're they're
basically behaving like gaussians it's
kind of some law law of large number
phenomenons going on and you can see
that it adheres pretty tightly to the
two this heuristic so this is the
heuristic and this is say R you are
using the discrete Gaussian to provide
okay that's a good question so the
question was are we using the discrete
Gaussian here and that was one of the
experiments we also did continuous
Gaussian so it's just like a way was up
as a sanity check and then uniform over
plus or minus one and then some another
distribution so yes this this does hold
for screech Gaussian entries so morally
what this is telling us is that like if
your sub gaseum that's no worse than
being Gaussian yes yeah but is there is
there an example of an uncommon
distribution for which this result
doesn't hold for like you can be sub
Gaussian and have independent entries
and still somehow have larger singular
values then I haven't found it but I'm
sure there is because it seems like this
sub Gaussian machinery is just too big
of a hammer for like the commonly use
distributions in cryptography but I
would expect that
could find one yeah I see yeah because
importantly here we're using independent
entries right and this is for this
weaker bond is four independent rows oh
so you're saying with independent
entries probably this probably this is
just true for also cows hands but with
independent rows that's much more subtle
potentially I don't know if I'd go that
okay yeah I guess your mouth sorry
yeah yeah some Gaussian it's also a very
broad umbrella of distributions right so
it's we we didn't explore to too far
under this umbrella we kind of just
stayed home and isolated okay and then
yeah so these are some experiments as
the mention increases and it holds for
for the matrices or here here that this
is just for uniform over plus or minus
one but we saw a similar behavior for
every distribution we talked about
before thank you any any questions
okay so I'll clap you can delete
yourselves and clap if you're into that
[Applause]
okay so now questions okay so maybe I'll
go first
so you had Chris's convolution theorem
right so Chris convolution theorem I
hope I remember correctly it says that
like you should sample like a continuous
Gaussian and then you should sample from
a discrete Gaussian shifted by the
continuous Gaussian that you sampled
right um and you're saying that like the
framework that you provided in the first
half of the talk like doesn't exactly
account for this because like it doesn't
exactly account for when the shift
depends on like one of the gaussians or
like the first gaussian or whatever um
but then you like jumped really quickly
to sort of not care about that anymore
you switch to to a different
distribution where you're just sort of
adding up two gaussians right so let me
okay yeah see if I got this clear
so you're saying here that you could
take this to be continuous right oh okay
yeah so I know it is being continuous
but fine you take it to be described
that doesn't bother so right but in in
Chris's paper in 2010 the general
statement is for discrete Gaussian so we
don't we don't beat that by any means
and if you take this this a 1 here this
lambda 1 if you make it denser and
denser the the continuous statement does
pop out or should pop up sure okay but
I'm asking some much dumber which is
like what step did you like what was the
step that you took to to fix this x1
being in the like being in their own
place okay what do you mean by the wrong
place yeah like so you have that the
shift of 8 that you take for the second
discrete Gaussian depends on X 1 but
your your theorem I think it doesn't
work for that right your theorem she
should take two gaussians that are sort
of predetermined and like add them up or
something right okay yeah so that that's
what we talked about joint distribution
so I did I did make a jump so that's
that's this this statement here so you
express it as one discrete Gaussian I
see I see and so this is like just this
is like another like another application
of smoothness yes exactly a
pre-processing right right
smoothness here all we need is that this
the second part is smooth because we're
which were randomly shifting right and
smoothness is it helps us in terms of
shift invariance you're saying like this
is like a more immediate application of
smoothness cool yes yeah all right
thank you thank you all for for coming
okay who did that that's cool okay um so
so thanks everyone maybe we'll stick
around for a little longer in case
people have questions but I guess I'll
stop the recording now and thanks Nick
yeah thank you for having